foreign
welcome back it is time to talk some
hockey we welcome former golden Knight
and channel 8 hockey expert Derek
England back here and Derek it is the
eve of the Stanley Cup Final here in Las
Vegas game one tomorrow yeah it's
exciting times for the city and and the
team for the whole organization let's
talk about uh what do the players
probably thinking right now because it's
such a big moment the veterans that have
been there some have won the cup that
are playing on the knights team but some
of these guys have never been there and
now this is their first opportunity yeah
I think you're probably uh you know
getting there it's kind of worn off
you're just ready to get going because
you know the media day and and the
practices leading up to it you just want
to get started and get going and just
that's what you do all season long so
you just want to get the games going get
ready into the battle and then and get
going well it's the nights taking on the
Florida Panthers and when you think of
Florida boy you think of all those teams
it's kind of like you guys in 2018 a
magical run here yeah you know if you go
back to the beginning of the season I
think a lot of hockey experts had them
picked to be pretty good pretty good
this year they came all the gates a
little slow but they've been playing
playoff hockey for a long time they've
beat some good teams so they're clicking
on all cylinders and I think it's going
to be a great uh great matchup yeah I
think Pittsburgh had to win a couple
games that allowed the Panthers to get
into the postseason and look what
they've done they've knocked off three
of the top teams in the league to face
the knights yeah they've come out you
know after the 3-1 deficit to Boston
they've come over brovsky's gone in and
has been extremely well done extremely
well for him so you got to figure out
him early on and get traffic in front of
them and get them off his game a little
bit or it's gonna be a lot of fun when
you think of the uh the Panthers you
think of the knights coming off that
real impressive win over Dallas which
was really impressive they shut him
right down and and looked like they were
going to be now rolling into the Cup
Final yeah you've heard a lot of people
it was almost the perfect game even Pete
Deboer said they were they were ready to
go they played a near-perfect game I
don't think you can ever play a perfect
game but it was as close as you're gonna
get to it and I think it was uh fueled
by that fourth line coming out the first
shift dominated their second shift to
get a goal so they're fueling off them
and uh you know they're going to need a
lot more of that coming up you know
what's kind of fun too and we talked
about that today a media day was how the
Misfits are playing such a big part of
this run yeah you know right on the back
in Theo and McNabb D Partners they're
playing extremely well against tough
tough opponents and then Margie Smith
Carlson will carrier all of them have
contributed in one way or another so
it's uh it's fun to see them back here
again five years later all right Derek
before let's go let's go back to 2018
and and the city was just absolutely on
fire this team that came out of nowhere
suddenly in the Cup Final yeah it was uh
electric that year it was uh you know
the craziest thing I've seen uh you know
I thought it was all year long I thought
it was and then you got to the finals
and it was just another level so I
expect to see that uh here it's been
pretty uh amazing around town already so
it's going to be even bigger coming up
here we got about 30 seconds to go what
what how do you predict this final to go
uh
yeah I think it's going to be a battle
they're going to play a physical game
you know Matthew to Chuck I've played
with him in in Calgary and I think they
really feed off his energy and how he
plays so uh it's gonna be a I think it's
going to be a physical battle and uh
it's going to be some tight tight games
does it go all seven
oh man
as a fad I want to say yes because
there's nothing better than a Stanley
Cup final game seven
um but as a as a night uh you know
working and you know bleeding gold I
guess you could say hopefully it's a
short series all right we'll see what
happens it all starts tomorrow five
o'clock over at The Fortress T-Mobile